what should politicians do with their
time
jobs for MPS I don't have any objection
um to MPS having a an insight into the
outside world second jobs divide MPS and
often anger their voters you get paid
best part of 90 grand a year that should
be enough we've voted them in to run
this country so that's what they should
do Sky News is Westminster accounts
project has followed the money through
our political system now we reveal the
scale of MP's commitment to their second
jobs
for the first time we can show you the
total of how much time MPS say they
spend on their outside work nearly 89
000 hours that's the total amount of
time all MPS have worked in second jobs
over the course of this Parliament so
three and a half years let's see how it
all breaks down these are the MPS who
commit the most hours to their second
jobs
there are some names in there you might
recognize Sir Jeffrey Cox they've become
notorious for their commitment to
outside work but most have one thing in
common all the names on this list have
second jobs in politics councilors
Mayors members of the Scottish
Parliament double political job in
keeping them very busy
and something else we can show you for
the very first time this is the average
hourly wage of an MP in a second job
233 pounds per hour
how does that compare to the rest of the
population well it's a lot higher the
average hourly wage for an MP in a
second job is over 17 times the average
rate for a member of the UK public and
more than 22 times the minimum hourly
wage
which MPS are getting the most cash for
the hours they work this leaderboard
shows you that these 20 MPS have the
highest hourly rates in Parliament the
name of the top is no surprise Boris
Johnson now free to spend even more time
earning big bucks away from Westminster
the second name on this list is the
shortest live PM in British history but
that has hardly dented her earnings
power Liz truss her most lucrative work
since leaving number 10 has been a
speech in Taiwan paid at a rate of 20
000 pounds an hour nearly one and a half
thousand times the UK average hourly
wage for her insights into Global
diplomacy and that's part of a very
common pattern MPS who've served in
government dominate this leaderboard 18
of the MPS with the highest hourly
earnings this Parliament have government
experience clearly a very lucrative
addition to any parliamentarian CV
plans for major second job reforms have
Frozen in this Parliament is it just a
matter of time until voters force a
change Samco Sky News